will firstly let me say that I welcome
the fact that a deal has been done I
think that most people in society out
there will welcome the fact that we're
at the end of this negotiation that's it
complete
um and I think that you know most
people's minds here at home will very
much quickly turn to the fact that we
need to be in this institution we need
to be working together we need to be
tackling things like the Health Service
you know creating jobs growing our
economy Tech and the full advantage that
the protocol affords us I think that as
I speak to you right now the details are
still a common hot off the press we're
working our way through
um all of that detail and we'll probably
have more to say about that because
we're going to meet this evening
continue to make the season just as a
party in terms of analyzing all of that
detail but I welcome the fact that a
deal has been done we've always said
that it was possible to have a day we've
always said that with pragmatism
solutions could be found so the fact
that both sides have arrived at that
point today and this represents the end
of the negotiation I think is something
that will be well received
[Music]
well as I said the detail of the deal is
actually just common hard off the press
as I speak to you right now my inbox is
following up with information and we
need to make our way through all of that
but I was always very clear that
um the protections that were secured
within the protocol were necessary they
remained necessary
um the fundamental priorities for us
were the protection of the Good Friday
agreement the all Island economy you
know work protecting those things that
we're working and then smoothing out the
things that needed to be fixed I hope
that that's the position that we're
starting in um this evening and we'll
work our way through all the detail and
throughout the course of the common
hours
[Music]
well I know where we need to be all
political parties need to be sitting
around the executive table taking
decisions that impact on people's lives
that's where we should be today there
shouldn't be any delays in that fencing
we have a Health Service and crisis
we're public sector workers out on the
picket line where we need to be is
making politics work and starting up for
the people that we represent
collectively and I think that's where
all energies and efforts need to be now
that's where my attention is focused
excuse me
supporter of the protocol as the
inevitable consequence of brexit do you
think this framework removes anything
that would cause you some concern that's
no longer there
so I think we
continue to work our way through the
detail of that and we say a lot more
about it whenever we have that chance to
to go through all things but I mean I've
always been very clear that we need to
maintain the protections that were embed
to the protocol from what has been said
this afternoon that appears to be the
case and that's very very important but
I do hope that the solutions found and
there appears to be Solutions found and
some pragmatism around some of the
issues and that's a welcome thing
yeah what I've said consistently
throughout the whole of the brexit
debate is that the people here have been
left and limbo they've left with
uncertainty I'm hoping that today
because we're at the end of the
negotiation the deal is now done I'm
hoping that today all energy and efforts
focus at home here to make a politics
work and actually getting around the
executive table Rebecca Black
sorry
what's the next step by
this agreement is
but I think the people at home will be
sitting today and with the realization
that a deal is now done and the
negotiation is complete I think their
minds will very quickly turn to now what
does that mean for our local politics
and I think their minds will very
quickly turn to they all need to now be
around the executive table that's where
I'm ready to be that's what Conor's
ready to be and we encourage all parties
to come at it from that point of view go
ahead UTV
how confident
will return and how soon
on the basis of this deal
well there's no other show in town the
Good Friday agreement is the basis in
which we all govern together here and
it's where all parties should be we're
dealing with many many sad issues out
there the fact that our health services
in crisis the fact that public sector
workers are out in strike prefer pay and
conditions we need to make politics work
I mean this is the 25th anniversary of
the Good Friday agreement I Believe In
The Good Friday agreement I believe in
the apparatus of the Good Friday
agreement and I genuinely believe that
all parties are best served sitting
around the executive table so I
encourage everybody to do that
of yourself
well I mean I welcome the fact that a
deal has been done we've always knew
that a deal could be done if there was
the right attitude so I think that
that's been born out and we now have a
solution on the table and I encourage
the dup to join with the rest of the
parties and actually make politics work
here let's get around the executive
table and take on the issues that are
important to people every day that's
what the public voted for in last May's
election and they deserve no less than
that I'm ready I stand ready my team are
ready and I need Partners in which to
govern and we ask all the other
political parties to be around the
executive table together
is something that
would again the details are still common
directly towards us so we provide more
analysis of that I think over the course
of the the common art